- [Narrator] Ladies and gentlemen,
we all know that the
American flag has endured,
in its many forms,
as the ultimate symbol
of freedom, justice,
and the American way,
but did you know that our nation's flag
was designed by a high
school student from Ohio?
("Yankee Doodle Dandy")
- [Narrator] According to legend,
the original American flag
from 1776 was sewn by a
lady named Betsy Ross.
It had 13 stars in a circle
representing America's
original 13 states.
As more states joined the union,
people kept adding more stars to the flag,
so by 1958 the US flag
had a total of 48 stars
for the 48 states of that time.
Which brings us to our high
school student, Robert Heft.
Robert's history teacher gave his students
an open-ended assignment.
"Make a project illustrating
"your interest in American history.
"It could be anything."
So, Robert, who was jazzed
about hearing that Alaska
and Hawaii were going to become states,
cut up an old 48 state flag
in his grandparents' basement
and designed his own
vision for a 50 state flag.
When he turned his final assignment,
Robert's teacher said,
"Anyone can make a flag,
"and it's got the wrong number of stars."
The grade came back a B minus.
Robert tried to explain his idea
to his teacher who replied,
"I'll change your grade
when your flag is accepted
"by the US Congress."
Game on.
Robert wrote 21 letters
and called The White House
18 times until one day in
1960, Robert's phone rang.
(phone rings)
- [Robert] Hello?
- [President Eisenhower]
Hello, Robert Heft?
- [Narrator] It was President Eisenhower
with news that Robert's
50 state flag design
had actually been chosen
as the new official flag
of the United States.
The President invited Robert
to Washington where he saw
his American flag fly for the
first time on July 4th, 1960.
Since then, Robert's 50 state
flag has remained unmatched
as the quintessential symbol of America.
But I know what you're thinking,
whatever happened to that B minus?
Robert's teacher honored his promise
and changed the grade to an A.